طيب خلال اللقاءات اللي شفتوها مع النجوم
اكثر منهم خلصونا بتصريحات حصريه او
مفاجات او اخبار جديده تفاعلكم كان له
ايضا السبت في مقابلات وتصريحات في مواضيع
اخرى عديده همت الراي العام
محمد عبده
كل التقدير والاحترام والمعزه والياسمين
مستحيل ان انا اتكلم فيها مش شخصيه لي انا
لوحدي في طرف ثاني فيها
توقعتك كمان ممكن تتكلم يعني انه تقول
ممكن صادق الشاعر يعني بس ما جبت سيرته بس
مو مشكله صادق الشاعر وسهم
قلت لك لك 67 سنه قاعده تلفي على سؤالك
ههه
[موسيقى]
موظفين المفوضيه هل هذا صحيح
ابدا ابدا غير صحيح
انه اه تحيه لزوجي وكذا ايوه صار كل احد
يبعث يقول زوجها من زوجها فين
يشتغل والتحقيقات
زوجي بنتي ابني اذا ما عندهم يظهرون فانا
احترم خصيتهم من دشره
نايف معه وكذا وانه هذا ابنه وحيد هل هذه
الصوره حقيقيه
لا لا لا الولد هذا الله يخليه له هلا هذا
ابن الشاعر والله ما يحسبني اسمها اللي
اللي كتب الاوبريت
كبير كرزون
ولا يجي
خلصنا منها
ان ده ضابط اسرائيلي يعني
وتم اغتياله يعني ما فهمتش الحقيقه بس انا
اخذتها الضحكه
ما نعتبر
منك
حتى لو زعلتك ده انت فوق راسي الى وحده
الجرائم الالكترونيه ورفعت قضيه على الشخص
او الجهه اللي همم طلع الاشاعه ويتزوجوا
لها واللي علقوا عليها واللي شيروها لانه
هذول ايضا من شركاء بالجريمه في عالم رجل
طبعا نحن في عالم رجل
الممثل الفنان الممثل حتى لو كنتي انت
مثلا اعلى منه نجوميه هو بياخذ اكثر بهاء
الشعير يعني لا زالت تعلق عليك وتلمح مثلا
احيانا صراحه بالاسم واحيانا تلميحات وما
الى ذلك ليش مستمر هذا الصراع
الله اعلم
ما عندي تعليق انت رفعتي عليها قضيه
كلنا حبايبها يا الهام قد ناس تدري عارفه
في قضايا وايد
[ضحك]
فعوها والفران
فنان كبير
يعني هو انت لوحدك مفاجاه جميله جدا
المفاجاه الجميله الي معك الله الله الله
الله
اهلا اهلا بالست جليله ازيك يا حبيبتي
طبعا انا لسه ههه
صبمر فيها لسه شغاله يعني الحمد لله ههه
بصي المسلسل
طبعا اكيد حلال طيب وشو وين لا شهود راح
يكون على التلفون
تمثل للوطن العربي وهذا فخر لي انا مسامحك
من قلبي وهو نفسه لو عايش كان اخذ الموضوع
بطريقه لطيفه
من قبل عدد كبير من الاشخاص طلاب زائد
حسابات وهميه في دول ممكن ينتقل من حدا
لحدا بس بالنهايه بده ينشغل انت يمكن اول
فنانه اقابلها ترددها الرد
العظيم رد